[Música]
Moscú denuncia dos nuevos ataques contra
refinerías en Rusia una ofensiva con
drones que se suma a los incidentes de
los últimos días y que llevan la guerra
en Ucrania a territorio ruso
en Francia Emmanuel macron gana una
nueva batalla en la lucha por la reforma
de las pensiones al impedir el debate
sobre una iniciativa de la oposición que
pretendía suspender la impopular
legislación Tenemos reporte desde París
en Estados Unidos en la cuenta atrás
para evitar que el país entre en impago
la cámara de representantes empieza este
miércoles el debate para Elevar el techo
de la deuda después de que la casa
blanca y los republicanos alcanzarán un
primer acuerdo ampliamos desde
Washington
Buenas tardes Bienvenidos a las noticias
de frank34 en español Soy Rosa Pérez
mazeu y es para mí un gusto acompañarles
abrimos con información de la guerra en
Ucrania porque se intensifican los
ataques contra Rusia las autoridades
rusas denunciaron una ofensiva con
drones contra refinerías de petróleo en
la región de krasnodar fronteriza con
Ucrania recordemos que en los últimos
días y semanas se han multiplicado
hechos similares ayer ocho drones
cayeron en Moscú y otros dos impactaron
contra el kremlin el pasado 3 de mayo
estas imágenes granuladas de circuito
cerrado de televisión muestran el
momento en el que se declaró un incendio
en una refinería de petróleo rusa en la
madrugada del miércoles según un
gobernador local la refinería de afipsky
fue atacada por drones ucranianos es una
de las dos plantas que fueron objetivo
el miércoles junto a otra en ilski ambas
se encuentran en la región de krasnodar
a 1000 km al sur el pueblo de sebequino
parte de vergorot justo al otro lado de
la frontera ucraniana también fue
alcanzado el martes los proyectiles
causaron daños en los edificios así como
heridas a los residentes
Hola queridos amigos esta mañana no es
buena para nosotros por la noche o más
bien a las 3:15 de la mañana se llevó a
cabo un ataque masivo con misiles en
Shrek benico mucha destrucción edificios
y departamentos casas particulares
muchos vehículos quemados cuatro
personas resultaron heridas están
recibiendo asistencia médica gracias a
dios Nadie murió
los trabajos de restauración comenzarán
hoy
en respuesta Rusia ha dicho que evacuará
cientos de niños de los pueblos de la
región el kremlin califica la situación
de preocupante
estamos preocupados por esta situación
el bombardeo de instalaciones civiles
continúa allí Por cierto no hemos oído
ni una palabra de condena de Ninguno de
los países de occidente en colectivo la
situación allí es bastante alarmante se
están tomando medidas
al otro lado de la frontera en Luján
también hubo ataques contra la pequeña
aldea de carpati que está ocupada por
Rusia funcionarios instalados en Moscú
dijeron que un puñado de residentes
murieron en la ofensiva los últimos
ataques se producen menos de 24 horas
después de que tres drones alcanzarán un
edificio Residencial en Moscú causando
solo daños leves pero provocando
evacuaciones ataques que el presidente
Vladimir Putin calificó de provocación
cambiamos de información en Francia en
la asamblea nacional el partido de
Manuel macron y sus aliados de la
derecha conservadora lo republicanos
bloquearon un nuevo intento de la
oposición para derogar la impopular
reforma de las pensiones antes de que
entren vigor en septiembre el gobierno
impide así el debate pero el movimiento
sigue en las calles hay nueva
convocatoria de marchas el próximo
martes 6 de junio desde París Luis
Miguel Cabrera nos tiene de los detalles
otra Victoria para el gobierno de Manuel
macron los diputados afines al
mandatario lograron despojar de sentido
el proyecto de ley que busca derogar la
reforma de pensiones aprobada la fuerza
por el gobierno de Elizabeth bonda sin
embargo sus promotores no se dan por
vencidos luego de abandonar la sala de
forma intempestiva e intentar
obstaculizar el debate sugirieron que
introducirán una enmienda al proyecto de
ley con el mismo objetivo derogar la
reforma de pensiones sería esa la única
forma y la primera vez en que la
asamblea en pleno podría votar
específicamente la edad de jubilación de
los franceses y también el último
recurso antes de que la reforma entre en
vigor en septiembre de este año problema
la presidenta de la cámara baja podría
desestimar la iniciativa basada
nuevamente en otro acapite de la Carta
Magna francesa relacionado con las
finanzas del Estado otra vez el gobierno
y sus legisladores en tela de juicio por
lo que la oposición cataloga como otro
atropello legal pero legítimo a la
voluntad popular para la primera
ministra sin embargo toda esta maniobra
es una venta de ilusión una estrategia
demagógica de la oposición que le viene
como anillo al dedo a pocos días de la
décimo cuarta jornada Nacional de
protestas contra la reforma de pensiones
prevista para el próximo martes
y nueva escena de tensión en el mar de
China el pentágono acusa a Beijing de
que un avión de combate chino llevó a
cabo una maniobra excesivamente agresiva
cerca de una aeronave militar
estadounidense en espacio aéreo
internacional y este miércoles el
secretario de estado de Estados Unidos
Anthony blinken lamentó que dadas las
circunstancias el ministro de defensa
Chino Li shang-fu rechace una reunión
con el Secretario de Defensa
estadounidense Lloyd Austin blinken
sostuvo que lo más peligroso es no
comunicarse
vamos a Estados Unidos donde este
miércoles empieza el debate en la cámara
de representantes sobre el techo de la
deuda esto después de que el presidente
Joe biden y el líder de los republicanos
en la cámara baja Kevin mccarthy
llegarán a un primer acuerdo nuestro
corresponsal en Washington Cristóbal
Vázquez nos Explica cómo se presenta
este debate
se presenta con mucha expectativa
teniendo en cuenta que ha habido
campañas de cabildeo bastante duras por
parte de la republicano presidente de la
cámara representante Kevin mccarthy y
del presidente
bidenyana llamado a decenas de
congresistas personalmente para contar
con el apoyo lograr esa mayoría de más
de 218 votos en la cámara de
representantes se sobreentiende que los
radicales conservadores republicanos y
los más liberales demócratas no van a
apoyar este proyecto por las quejas que
plantean ellos los radicales
conservadores dicen que no es suficiente
el presupuesto que se designó para
defensa en los próximos años y los
liberales dicen que no hay suficiente
plata para los programas sociales Así
que ellos están excluidos de ese apoyo
que quieren lograr tanto en los
moderados republicanos y los moderados
demócratas para pasar este proyecto de
ley y evitar el deporte financiero que
según se empezaría a dar a partir de el
cinco de junio
es decir este fin de semana tendría
Entonces el senado una vez sea aprobado
acá en cámara de representantes este
proyecto de ley para levantar el techo
de la deuda del senado tendría Entonces
el fin de semana Para probarlo también y
que sea yo quien lo firme ya como
ley en otras noticias en Sudán el
ejército regular suspende su
participación en los diálogos con los
paramilitares que se celebran en lleda
Arabia Saudita recordemos que las
negociaciones auspiciadas por riad y
Washington fueron el marco donde se
acordaron las treguas humanitarias que
ambos bandos se han acusado de violar
sistemáticamente
en Sudán las partes en conflicto no
parecen querer silenciar las armas el
ejército suspendió su participación en
las conversaciones de tregua con las
fuerzas de apoyo rápido el anuncio lo
hizo un funcionario del gobierno sudanés
quien explicó que la decisión fue tomada
puestos paramilitares nunca respetaron
ningún acuerdo de tregua las fuerzas de
apoyo rápido reaccionaron en Twitter a
pesar del fracaso de las fuerzas armadas
sudanesas en el cese de las hostilidades
las fuerzas de apoyo rápido apoyan
incondicionalmente la iniciativa saudi
estadounidense la recientes violaciones
de las fuerzas armadas sudanesas no nos
han disuadido de cumplir nuestros
compromisos la decisión del ejército no
fue una sorpresa total el lunes los
mediadores estadounidenses y sauditas
anunciaron que las dos partes
prorrogarían por otros cinco días una
tregua humanitaria que debía expirar ese
mismo día pero al día siguiente los
combates volvieron a
de ser Incluso el jefe del ejército
apareció arrendando a sus tropas en las
calles de jartum
no queremos destruir el país pero si el
enemigo no obedece nos veremos obligados
a utilizar Nuestra fuerza máxima tras
siete semanas de combates la situación
humanitaria se vuelve cada vez más
preocupante según la ONU 25 millones de
una población de 45 millones necesitan
ayuda para sobrevivir la guerra ha
provocado al menos 1800 muertes y ha
desplazado a casi un millón y medio de
personas entre ellos 350.000 refugiados
unas cifras oficiales ampliamente
subestimadas según los expertos
cambiamos de información occidente da
pasos incipientes en La regulación de la
Inteligencia artificial la Unión Europea
y Estados Unidos anunciaron que en las
próximas semanas publicarán un código de
conducta común sobre esta tecnología la
noticia llega después de que un grupo de
científicos lanzará una nueva
advertencia sobre los peligros de la
Inteligencia artificial
tan breve como contundente esta
declaración firmada por más de 350
expertos en tecnología hace un llamado a
los responsables políticos mitigar el
riesgo de extinción por la Inteligencia
artificial Debería ser una prioridad
global junto a otros riesgos a escala
social como las pandemias y la guerra
nuclear el centro para la seguridad de
la Inteligencia artificial señala varios
escenarios catastróficos como que las
herramientas de descubrimiento de
fármacos se utilizan para crear armas
químicas o el debilitamiento en el que
la humanidad pierde la capacidad de
autogobernarse y pasa a depender
completamente de las máquinas entre Los
partidarios de la declaración se
encuentran ejecutivos de Google y
Microsoft y Goofy gington considerado
uno de los padrinos de la Inteligencia
artificial
en cuanto a la amenaza existencial creo
que quizá Estados Unidos china Europa y
Japón puedan cooperar para intentar
evitar esa amenaza existencial pero la
cuestión es como hacerlo creo que
detener el desarrollo no es factible
otras figuras de la industria sin
embargo dicen que los temores en torno a
la extinción humana son exagerados y
muchos creen que el verdadero problema
de la ia es la reproducción de
prejuicios aprendidos en sistemas
racistas O excluyentes
creo que estos son algunos de los
ámbitos la contratación y el empleo es
uno los préstamos abusivos son otro el
acceso a la vivienda el acceso a
oportunidades de desarrollo como la
admisión en la universidad y en la
escuela
la declaración sigue a una carta mucho
más larga firmada por más de 1000
expertos incluido y los musk consejero
delegado de tesla en ella se pedía Una
pausa en el desarrollo de la
Inteligencia artificial de Nueva
Generación
advirtiendo que las Mentes no humanas
podrían llegar a ser más inteligentes y
sustituirlos
y hoy es el Día Mundial sin tabaco y
este año la OMS instaló los gobiernos a
dejar de subvencionar el cultivo de
tabaco y en su lugar apoyar las
plantaciones de alimentos para combatir
la inseguridad alimentaria
una conmemoración anual que se remonta A
1987 el Día Mundial sin tabaco fue
instaurado por los estados miembros de
la Organización Mundial de la Salud para
advertir al público de las enfermedades
y muertes evitables que causa esta
sustancia Según la OMS el consumo de
tabaco mata a más de 8 millones de
personas cada año aumenta
significativamente el riesgo de los
consumidores de desarrollar enfermedades
respiratorias y cardiovasculares así
como más de 20 tipos o subtipos
diferentes de cáncer la organización
también señala que el 80% de los
consumidores proceden de países de
ingresos bajos y medios y que la mayoría
de las muertes relacionadas con el
tabaco también proceden de estos países
el lema de la celebración de este año es
cultiva alimentos no tabaco la campaña
pretende animar a los gobiernos a que
dejen de financiar el cultivo de tabaco
y en su lugar apoyen los cultivos que
alimentan a millones de personas y es
que los recientes conflictos el impacto
económico de la pandemia y los efectos
del cambio climático han contribuido a
una crisis alimentaria mundial
hay más de 350 millones de personas con
problemas de hambre e inseguridad
alimentaria y muchos de los países donde
estos problemas son preocupantes son
también grandes economías productoras de
tabaco en África por ejemplo en los
últimos 15 años el cultivo de tabaco ha
aumentado casi un 20%
la OMS también subraya que cambiar el
tabaco por cultivos alimentarios
mejorarían los medios de subsistencia de
los cultivadores de tabaco ya que muchos
sufren problemas de salud debido a los
productos químicos nocivos que utilizan
para cultivarlo
llegamos así al final de esta edición
pero sigan con nosotros que enseguida
volvemos
[Música]